the two larger mysteries mating and
calving remain unanswered but blue
whales are behaving differently here
than in California
meters in front of me
John takes photographs that reveal
behavior sometimes called sharking the
animal swims rapidly on its side and
displays half a fluke above the Seas
surface
at the dome blue whales seem to be doing
plenty of sharking and this sharking
work this maneuver where the flukes are
half seen or pectoral flippers out of
water as an animal rapidly moves in
rotating underneath another another
animal those are the things we think are
all the elements of getting ready to
meet there's more interesting behavior
three or more whales are engaging in
hidden activity
it's really unusual that three whales
together this logging at the surface
hardly moving at all usually when you
get these trios are really active
interacting with these guys are just
relaying at the surface hardly moving
I've never seen this good
you